die nasa schlägt einen revolutionären
antrieb für raumschiffe vorstadt
chemische antriebe bei denen unmengen an
treibstoff transportiert werden müssen
schlagen sie einen photonen antrieb vor
mit ihm könnten relativistische
geschwindigkeiten erreicht werden die
deutlich höher als sie der chemischen
raketenantriebe werden wie funktioniert
das jetzt in klicks und science fiction
herzlich willkommen raketenantriebe
haben einen fast schon tragische
nebeneffekt umso weiter und schneller
ich reisen möchte desto mehr treibstoff
muss ich mitnehmen um so mehr treibstoff
ich brauche also mit nehme desto mehr
treibstoff brauche ich auch um wiederum
diesen treibstoff zu transportieren und
so weiter und so fort es ist ein fast
jedes ziel
umso mehr treibstoff ich brauche desto
mehr treibstoff brauche ich für einen
mars-flug sind so wahre unmengen nötig
damit das überhaupt klappt müssen die
missionen wie die zum mars auch im
weltraum betankt werden bzw
dort müssen tanks gesammelt werden und
anders raum schrift montiert werden ein
wahnsinniger aufwand deshalb schickt die
nasa einen photonen antrieb vor er kommt
ohne treibstoff an bord aus dabei werden
am raumschiff sonnensegel montiert die
von der erde aus mit lasern beschossen
werden oder von satelliten in der
erdumlaufbahn und so innerhalb kürzester
zeit werden sie auf extrem hohe
geschwindigkeiten beschleunigt seine
technik wie sie auch für das break star
schott projekt geplant ist bei dem mini
sondern auch vor geschwindigkeiten
beschleunigt werden sollen um dann unser
nächstes sternensystem alpha centauri
innerhalb von 20 jahren zu erreichen da
vermuten wir ja mögliches außerirdisches
leben aber auch hier im sonnensystem
könnte die technik für deutlich
schnellere flüge zwischen den planeten
genutzt werden der leitende physiker der
machbarkeitsstudie die zurzeit entsteht
ist philipp lubin von der university of
california in santa barbara zitat
elektromagnetische beschleunigung ist
nuss und grenzt durch die
lichtgeschwindigkeit chemische systeme
sind begrenzt durch die menge an energie
die durch die chemischen prozesse
erzeugt werden
zitat ende der treibstoff ist also das
nadelöhr der bisherigen konventionellen
antrieb rubin setzt deshalb auf photonen
antrieb kern des systems ist ein
sogenanntes die star for system
es kann die energie von 50
atomkraftwerken für einen laser
bereitstellen damit kann es asteroiden
abwehren oder eben auch raumschiffe
antreiben beim break star show project
sollen damit wenige gramm schwere mini
sonden auf 26 prozent der
lichtgeschwindigkeit beschleunigt werden
sie könnten dann in knapp 20 jahren
alpha centauri erreichen zwei nachteile
hat diese idee sie würden wahnsinnig
schnell durch das sternsystem rasen und
könnten nur sehr kurz daten erheben und
sie könnten auch nur minimale funktionen
haben weil sie so klein sehen zum
beispiel könnte jede sonne zum beispiel
nur nur ein foto machen und zur erde
funkte es geht aber in unserem
sonnensystem auch anders größere sonden
und nicht ganz so geschwindigkeiten ein
100 kilogramm schweres raumschiff könnte
zum beispiel auf ein prozent der
lichtgeschwindigkeit beschleunigt werden
und den mars so in drei tagen erreichen
die raumsonde voyager die als erste
sonde bisher in den interstellaren raum
außerhalb unseres sonnensystems erreicht
hat die könnte innerhalb von wenigen
tagen überholt werden und so weiter und
so fort
lookeen arbeitet im moment weiter an
seiner machbarkeitsstudie
ich bin extrem gespannt wie hoch die
kosten für ein solches projekt werden
und wie schnell es umsetzbar wäre also
sobald es neues gibt erfahrt ihr es
natürlich hier wenn er die
weiterentwicklung nicht verpassen wollt
dann drückt man hier ein aber aufs auge
und vergesst nicht den auf die glocke
denn nur dann werdet ihr auch über neue
themen informiert er geht es weiter also
einfach drauf kriegen mit reise zu
aliens nur 20 jahre zum nächsten stern
wo ich mich näher mit dem projekt break
star schott befassen also ansonsten bis
dann bleibt